[Music]
exactly four months ago I told you I was
building a new platform to host my
content from scratch called fire ship IO
and today is the day I finally get to
show it to you but I want to first start
by saying thank you to everybody who
supports this channel it's amazing to
even have the chance to build something
like this which wouldn't be possible
without this YouTube channel and this
community and it's the community that
really drives me to pursue the mission
of fire ship IO which is to create
resources that increase developer
happiness and productivity but the crazy
thing is if you were to ask me where do
I see myself in two years in January
2017 it definitely wouldn't be here at
that point I hadn't made a single video
and didn't even think I was capable of
doing a voiceover let alone producing a
video that anybody would want to watch I
probably would have gotten started a lot
sooner had it not been for self-doubt so
if you're thinking about doing something
like this my recommendation is to just
go for it
this channel is approaching a hundred
thousand subscribers which is just crazy
but I feel like we're barely just
getting started there's so much amazing
technology that is accessible to the
average developer and I really hope I
can help unlock those technologies so
people can build products that make
other people's lives better so that's my
motivation for building fire ship but
why am i building this instead of
continuing with angular firebase com let
me first point out that it's not because
my opinion of the underlying technology
has changed in fact they're only getting
better and I used angular and firebase
to build fire ship IO so the real
motivation behind this change is that I
want full control over the platform so I
can offer more content at a lower price
to everybody if you're an existing Pro
member you know that we have some of the
content on the main site some of it's
hosted on teachable as full courses and
some of it is on Lane pub in the form of
an e-book with fire ship everything is
under one roof so there's no jumping
back and forth between platforms in
addition the name change makes it more
flexible to cover additional content
outside of angular and firebase like
rust flutter etcetera and third I'm a
developer and I like building cool [ __ ]
so [ __ ] it it was something to do but is
it actually cool well I'll give you the
tour and you can decide one of the most
fundamental goals is to present content
in a way that's friendly for developers
the overall theme somewhat resembles a
vs code and the code snippets themselves
are designed
look like tabs in your editor so you
should notice a huge improvement in the
aesthetics of the site versus angular
firebase.com and everything is designed
with CSS variables which means we can
just click a button and switch over to a
light beam or a solarized theme if we
want and the total CSS payload for the
site is only six and a half kilobytes
the next thing you'll notice is the
search which is also designed to behave
similar to vs code the search is powered
by algo Leah simply start typing and
you'll see the results appear below the
next unique thing about the site is its
integration with slack if you're not
already a member of our slack Channel i
highly recommend you jump in there
because it's the best way to chat and
discuss content but the problem with
slack is that conversations are lost to
the slack archives and they're also very
hard to find if you're looking for
something specific so I decided to build
a slack bot that would take our
conversations about a specific post on
fire ship and miR them on the post
itself this is an alternative to
traditional blog post comments that I
think offers a better experience
especially for developers let's imagine
you have a question about a specific
lesson you simply grab the URL for that
lesson and ask a question to the
question bought on slack any replies on
that thread will go directly to the
comment section on the post itself this
means we can chat about a specific topic
without losing that valuable information
to the slack archives and if you have a
question slack is a much quicker way to
get a response on a question versus say
discuss comments or something similar
now getting back to the site itself my
goal is to release full courses with a
greater frequency I've decided to offer
the cloud functions master course for
free so all you have to do is log in to
fire ship i/o and you'll automatically
have access to the videos in this course
if you take this course all I ask is
that you give me some feedback about
what you'd like to see different or
improved with the course format now
let's talk about performance this is
easily the fastest site I've ever built
that is fully interactive it leverages
the full power of angular and firebase
yet can achieve first Paints in under
two seconds and lighthouse scores of 95
plus in the site's using web components
and we maintain stateful data between
those web components with a special
routing strategy this means you get page
transitions that are usually around 20
milliseconds I have log in for this
currently enabled so all you have to do
is open up the console navigate around
and you'll see how fast the page
transition actually is well at the same
time you'll see that your authentication
state if you're logged in does
change because that stapled data is
maintained between those changes and if
you want to see how I do all this you
can reverse engineer it because the
entire project is open sourced if we
look at the project on github you can
see that it's broken down into four main
projects we use hugo to manage the
content we use angular elements for the
interactive web components the CSS is
contained in the design folder and
lastly we have cloud functions for
everything on the backend so the
important thing here is that we can all
now collaborate to make this project
better so if you find a typo on the site
or some small issue you can simply open
up a pull request and contribute and
everything is wired up with continuous
delivery so once your pull request gets
merged it will automatically be deployed
to the live site there's so much more to
talk about here on the technical side of
things but I think I'll save that for a
live stream later this month so if you
have questions feel free to post them in
the comments below and I'll try to
answer them when we do that live stream
and I might even pick out a random
comment or two to win a t-shirt when we
do that stream now before we wrap things
up I want to talk about my future plans
I'm going to be shifting from develop
mode to content mode that just means I'm
going to be spending a lot of time
creating new content and also revising
past content on angular firebase comm I
will also be revising the stripe
payments course from scratch when that's
ready in the near future you'll be able
to build the exact same payment system
that I use for my apps I just want to
finish off by saying thank you to
everybody for all the continued support
it's the driving force behind all my
decision-making and I tried to sum that
up in a small manifesto that you can
read on the side thanks for watching and
I will talk to you soon